PETER: Tony wrote
the book on WebGL.
Literally.
"WebGL: Up and Running,"
and another one coming soon.
He will actually be raffling
off a couple of those books,
and you can get them
signed by the man himself.
So, big round of
applause for Tony.
[APPLAUSE]
TONY PARISI: Great,
thank you, Peter.
Thank you, Vanessa,
for organizing.
Many thanks to our hosts,
Google, and all the sponsors.
As Peter said, I'm Tony Parisi,
I run the SF WebGL meet-up.
A quick little bit about me,
you don't have to feverishly
write this down, these
slides will be on SlideShare.
And we'll post the link later.
So I've been doing 3D
visualization for the web
kind of as long as
that's been around.
It's coming on 20 years
now, I have to say.
Originally, working on a
technology called VRML.
Which many of you might
have heard of, some of you
might have played with in
middle school, a few of you
might have even
built something in.
And on and off for the last,
coming on, two decades,
I have been building
experiences in 3D
on the web with
whatever technology
was available at the time.
So I got very
excited around 2009
when I heard this thing,
WebGL, was coming out.
And after about a year of
trepidation and not wanting
to get to deep into it,
I finally jumped into it.
Year after that, I wrote
a book for O'Reilly,
"WebGL: Up and Running."
I've actually written
a second book,
which is an intermediate
level book-- the first one's
introductory-- it's
called, "Programming
3D Applications in
HTML5 and WebGL."
That's going to be out
in another month or so.
Right now you can get
the pre-release online,
Safari Online, through
Amazon, et cetera.
Enough of a plug.
And I do all this
stuff, and I consult,
and I have a little
start-up in the city that's
building 3D technology
on top of WebGL.
And so with that.
We live in a 3D world.
People move, and
they think, and they
experience in three dimensions.
These days, a lot of
our media is 3D as well.
Though, most of the time, we
experience it on a flat screen,
right?
But, the games we
play, the movies
we watch-- even if you
remember back to 2008 election,
the broadcast media we see
with Wolf Blitzer stumbling
around a virtual set awkwardly.
This has become a staple
of broadcast media now.
This is all done
with 3D graphics.
Which has been done on computers
for many, many decades.
Historically, it's been with
high-end, dedicated hardware
and very expensive
proprietary software.
Well, not anymore.
Now, the hardware you use to
render 3D runs on this phone,
it runs on this desktop, it
runs on this Kindle Fire HDX.
It runs everywhere.
3D accelerated hardware
is everywhere and powers
these real-time 3D
experiences we're
going to talk about today.
More importantly, the software
to create and experience
this stuff is not only
accessible everywhere,
it's free.
It's called a web browser.
Let's see if I have audio.
Do I have audio on the
presentation, here?
There we go.
OK, so this is "100,000 Stars."
This was a piece that was
developed by the Google Data
Arts team last year.
It's been around for
close to a year, now.
But to me, it illustrates
the strength of HTML5
as a platform, and
WebGL, which is
what we're going to
talk about tonight.
Now if you look at
this, you'll see
that I'm interacting
in real-time with a 3D
presentation that is running
in my Chrome browser.
And I can click on
a link, and it's
going to zoom me into the sun.
I don't know what's going on
with this little rectangle,
here.
We're going to ignore it.
That is craziness.
What's going on, here?
Is that my AV?
I'm going to try that again.
There we go.
All right, so you
see this virtual fly
through of our Milky Way Galaxy.
So imagine trying to
build this five years ago.
You would build this title,
you would distribute it
on a CD-ROM or DVD.
Right?
And people would maybe go into
Best Buy or order it on Amazon.
And if you built
this, the data for it
would have to be licensed.
See, I don't know
what that title is.
We're going to skip this.
Data for that would
have to be licensed.
And if you wanted
to update it, you'd
have to go get another CD.
We're just going
to let this play.
I'm sick of looking
at that title.
But now, it's running
a web browser.
And I don't know if
you noticed, but when
I clicked on one
of those links--
I'm going to try one more time
because I'm brave, there we go.
That's scraped from Wikipedia.
So we didn't have to go get
that stuff from Britannica
or anything like that.
So the world is
our encyclopedia.
This Encyclopedia
Galactica that's been built
was all built on HTML5.
This is now a rich
media platform,
and that's what we're
going to talk about today.
Back to our PowerPoint.
And so, who's seen this?
So that was a nice
visualization application,
but what we're
going to see here--
I'm going to bring up
Firefox for this one,
because it runs this
screamingly fast.
And hopefully, in
the browser cache.
Kind of big content.
This is an Epic Games Unreal
game that was converted from
their C++ code base.
Including an embedded
programming language
interpreter.
It was actually cross compiled
using a technology called
emscripten, compiled
to JavaScript,
and running in your web browser.
We are now live with
a full Unreal game
level in JavaScript,
rendered in WebGL.
Let's go to full screen.
I'll WASD around a little bit,
use the keyboard to navigate.
Use the arrow keys to
change the camera control.
I'll just go into
autopilot here,
so if you don't see me
driving and futzing around.
But look at this, benchmarking,
we're getting 30 FPS.
We can get higher
than that, I think.
That's probably because of the
display syncing and everything
else.
But, you know, fast machine,
you get 60 frames a second.
Running in your
browser, it's probably
about 20 megs of content coming
in to download that level.
That was a full Epic level.
We're talking AAA game stuff
running in our browser now.
And that is all
because we have WebGL.
What is WebGL?
It's the 3D API
standard for the web.
It's OpenGL ES.
Do people know what that is?
That is the software API
that runs on this phone.
And it runs on embedded systems.
Small devices.
That's what the ES stands
for, Embedded Systems.
You program to it
using JavaScript.
It's shipped pretty
much everywhere.
After initial
reluctance by Microsoft,
they've included it
in Internet Explorer.
It runs on the Kindle
Fire HDX like a bandit.
I can show you this stuff later.
Beautiful device, seven
inches of pure happiness
running 60 frames a second 3D.
I love this thing.
And supported everywhere
except mobile Safari,
but there are solutions.
We're actually building
HTML5 WebGL applications--
I'll talk about them
shortly-- for iOS.
But on Android, you
can use a browser,
or you can build a web app.
Kindle, web app, and on
and on the list goes on.
And in fact, it's coming
soon to a Bang and Olufsen
TV powered by Opera.
How about that?
On your TV, too.
So how does it work?
It's an API.
It is not a tag
set, it's not CSS.
You don't put a
little angle bracket
and say, cube, and see
a cube on the screen.
That'd be nice, maybe
that will happen someday.
So it's sort of
like Canvas drawing.
Has everyone done 2D
Canvas API drawing?
Are you quite familiar with it?
It's like that, but
different at the same time.
It's a low level
thing we're going
to talk about in a minute.
So no DOM, you've got to deal
with that stuff yourself.
Just like with Canvas, when
you want to deal with picking,
you have to kind of make
that stuff up as you go,
or use some tools, and I'm
going to show you those.
And there's no file
format built in.
I've seen so many people
ask questions online about,
how do I see my OBJ files or
my other 3D models in WebGL?
It's a bit of a modeling
error, because WebGL itself
doesn't support those.
The browser doesn't know how
to load a 3D file natively
and just show it to you.
You have to write code.
But thankfully, you can.
And thankfully, you can do it
in JavaScript, and it runs fast.
So we're going to quickly
go through the anatomy
of a simple WebGL program.
Breeze through it,
because there's
a lot of details to it
we don't have time for.
But the basic idea is, you
create a canvas element
on your page just like
you would for 2D drawing,
but then you get a
3D drawing context.
Where you'd get that 2D
context, you get a 3D context.
You create a viewport,
which basically
says the size of the
rectangle to draw into.
And then from there it
gets a little weird,
and we're going
to go through it.
All right, so this
is a kind of code,
if you're familiar with it.
You get a canvas
element somewhere,
we pass that into this function,
and it calls get context.
And it says, can I
have a WebGL context?
Older browsers, you have
to say experimental-WebGL,
but generally this is
supported now, WebGL.
If you don't succeed
at that, you probably
don't have WebGL support.
And you put up some kind of
friendly message for your user,
or do something
else to fall back.
And then, you
initialize the viewport.
In this case, what
I'm doing is I'm
going to draw to
the whole window.
Then you have to
create buffers of data
to represent your 3D objects.
Arrays of numbers in
JavaScript that you then
turn into this special new
thing called the typed array,
which you may have
heard of at this point.
This is binary data
that's very compact.
Runs very fast.
It was introduced into browsers
a few years ago largely because
of WebGL.
And that means that your 3D
data, which can be very rich,
is stored very compactly, and
you can operate on it quickly.
The other thing you
have to do, which
is a little new if
you're a web programmer,
is you have to create things
call programmable shaders.
If you know OpenGL ES already,
you're familiar with this.
You have to write code in
another programming language,
called OpenGL SL, which
is for Shader Language.
And it looks like C, sort of.
So for a C programmer, you'll
be kind of familiar with it.
And then there are some
built-ins if you look here.
It knows about matrices
and vectors and 3D thingies
already.
Because what happens is
that language gets compiled,
and these compiled
instructions actually
get sent to the graphics
card, and they're
executed on every vertex
that's rendered on the screen.
Every pixel that's
rendered on the screen.
And the hardware just
does it super fast.
This kind of technology came
out of Pixar, back in the day.
High-end renderings now brought
to every machine on the planet.
That's a little weird, though.
A little strange to
deal with, but we're
going to talk about
how we can avoid that.
And then we get
into some real weeds
here, which is you've got to
do a lot of low-level stuff.
GL itself, the API, is
kind of a state machine.
So you say, OK, that
buffer I created earlier,
I'm going to set it, and then
I'm going to draw with it.
And so we go through
and we do that.
We clear-- this is every frame.
You're doing a
RequestAnimationFrame kind
of draw a loop.
We clear the canvas.
We set up a shader.
Those buffers we created
before, we set them up.
We have to pass matrices in
to move our objects around.
All of this sort of
complicated stuff, right?
So you may be wondering
at this point,
how am I going to do this?
Really?
Seriously?
Well if you are a
game programmer,
you're a graphics
programmer, you're
probably familiar with how to
do that level of OpenGL coding.
You're good to go.
What you'll do is you'll
build your own engine
for your project.
Most people, though,
won't do that.
And the good news
is you don't have
to, because WebGL's
an open standard.
Because JavaScript
is fast enough,
people have written a whole
bunch of libraries, now, that
can actually talk to WebGL and
make things easier for you.
And we're going to see some
of those libraries in action
in a second.
For me, one of the
presenters tonight, Goo,
has actually got a great
engine with the creation
tool that comes along with it.
So you not only have an engine,
but you can build with it.
But there's a long list.
And you go online and you can
get these resources from me,
or other people, about where to
start in your creation process.
Unless you're a
glutton for punishment,
or you really, really want
to get to the low level,
you're probably not going
to do the stuff I showed you
a second ago.
You're going to use one of
these engines and tool kits.
And one of the ones I'm going
to talk to you about now
is called three.js.
Who's heard of three.js?
Use it every day.
Good, everybody.
That's great.
So all that funk we saw before--
the five, eight pages of code,
it was about 300
lines if I counted--
we get it onto a page, now.
And we're now
working with objects
that if you've got any
familiarity with 3D graphics,
or you can kind of get up
the learning curve fast,
they're the kind of
objects you'd think about.
It's a cube.
It's a camera that's
got a position in space.
It's a light that's going
to cast on to the object,
and you see some
shading here, right?
So that's the kind of
stuff you're probably
going to-- the level you're
probably going to work at,
and the kind of
stuff you're going
to be doing most days, right?
Three.js is really
cool, too, because it's
got a canvas renderer, an SVG
renderer, a CSS3 renderer.
It is a great engine.
I personally use
it for my projects,
and then I built a
framework on top of it
to make that
development even easier.
Because what three.js doesn't do
is a lot of high-level behavior
stuff, picking and other things.
You have to do some grunt-work.
So I've got a layer, but
this one is pretty great.
And some amazing things have
been built with it in the past.
I'll quickly show you.
This one right here, which
is the 360 Car Visualizer,
it's called.
Here we go.
So this stuff's
in browser cache.
Ought to load pretty fast.
But even with a clear cache,
it loads pretty quickly.
And we have a beautiful
interactive model
with a real-time shadow.
And this is great,
I mean, wonderful.
I've got a 3D model here.
I could spin it around.
That's excellent.
But what's most
excellent about this,
is I can really
configure this thing.
This is an interactive
application.
I'm going to switch
to another model.
I'm going to change
colors, right?
What online car
configurator would
be complete without being able
to select your colors, right?
Amazing.
There's a lot of polygon
detail on this thing, right?
A lot of beautiful shadows.
And the lights are
baked into the scene.
This stuff, here.
So that's part of the texture
map, the bitmap on the floor.
But everything
else is being done
in real-time,
including the shadows.
Oh yes, let's go back to Canary.
I'm going to show one more demo
of something fairly amazing.
This one was also done by the
Google Arts team, Data Arts
team.
Completely different from--
that was prosaic, right?
We had a real world physical
object we were showing.
This one's about data.
This is about looking
at the small arms
trade around the globe
for the last two decades.
Now, that's kind of
a sobering thought,
but it's very interesting.
So I can actually
slide these sliders
and go to different
periods of time
and look at the progression
of the arms trade.
I can look at just
imports or just exports.
I can actually zoom into
detail on a certain country,
like the Russian
Federation, and see
how they've been dealing
the last few decades.
And this was all built on
an open source Google globe
project, as well.
So you could go take
the data from this,
or the code from
this presentation,
put your own data in.
Let's say you wanted to look at
the epidemiology of, help me,
what's that virus
going around right
now everyone's
freaking out about?
H1N1, thank you.
We could see epidemiology
around the planet of that.
So this is the
kind of experience
we're talking about WebGL
being able to power.
But it goes beyond just
creating the models.
There's all this
amazing animation stuff
you can do with it, too.
You could do morphs and
skins, real-time characters.
And how do you do that?
That's a good question
I asked myself.
How do I make content for this?
The state of the art
right now is a little bit
like we've moved from the
stone tools age of creation
to the bronze age.
We're getting there,
the tools are coming.
You're going to see
Goo Create tonight.
That's a step in
the right direction.
What people are doing
today in these projects
I showed you, are, they're
exporting a single model.
An OBJ file or an
STL file or one
of these 3D formats that's
been around for a long time.
And then they're
hand animating it.
They're hand laying it out.
They're putting the lights in.
You basically-- your
modeler sitting in one room,
and he's like, Steve, yeah,
I put the light over here.
And he's talking
to the programmer,
and he's typing the things
in in a text editor again.
Well, that's changing.
That's changing.
There is a format that was
pretty rich and popular
for while, called COLLADA,
that took all the data.
The animations, the scenes,
the lights, the full hierarchy,
all this stuff, and got into
these big fat XML files.
And we've been
using that to show
some really sophisticated
WebGL lately.
But the problem is
they're big fat XML files.
They don't load fast, and
they're not tuned up for WebGL.
So there's this other
cool thing coming--
which I'm involved
in personally,
and we're going to see a
lightning talk from one
of the creators of, later--
which is called glTF.
The gl Transmission Format.
So imagine that
same rich data being
able to fully get into
your browser real quick.
Because all the vertex
datas and typed arrays,
only the stuff that
makes sense to have
in JSON, high-level
data, is in there.
And let's see if I got a
link to this puppy, here.
Love to show you this real
quick, it's my last demo.
Yes.
So on the load screen,
this six megabyte model
loaded in about 0.4 seconds.
Now that's what we need.
If any of you all are into
the web performance stuff,
and you go to Steve Souders'
talks, what do we know?
We know a web page has to load
in less than two seconds end
to end.
And that's a long time.
And you need to see
stuff on the screen a lot
more quickly than that.
Well, with these kind of
formats, we can do it.
And this is, of
course, just a movie.
I can switch the cameras, here.
And this came from
3D Studio Max.
It was converted to COLLADA.
Exported to COLLADA.
And then we ran a
converter on it--
that Fabrice is
going to speak later,
has written-- which takes the
COLLADA and turns it into glTF.
Nice and compact.
So that pipeline is
starting to come.
So all the professional tools,
3-D Studio Max, Maya, Blender,
SketchUp, they will
be able to support
this kind of experience.
Let's see if I can just
go out to the free camera
for a second, here.
We can see our little virtual
city in its full glory.
So there we go.
So, help's coming
on the pipeline.
Well, we talked about this
earlier, where does it run?
Well, it runs pretty
much everywhere.
I did mention that little
bump in the road with iOS.
For whatever reason,
Apple has not
turned on WebGL support
inside mobile Safari.
However, they do have it
running in a limited fashion
in their iADs platform.
So if you make an
iAD to be inserted
into someone's freemium
game, or whatever,
you've got full HTML5 that
you can use to build the iAD,
and includes WebGL.
But that's kind of limited.
It'd be really nice if
you could hit any website
with mobile Safari and
the WebGL would just work.
And it's a little frustrating
that it hasn't happened yet.
Tim Cook, if you're
listening, let's talk.
I'll even come
down to Cupertino.
I don't mind driving down there.
So hopefully that will
be fixed at some point.
It's not yet.
But the good news is
there are solutions today
that will let you take your
HTML5 app-- because I know
people here, in this
group especially, are
interested in building
their stuff once in HTML5
and then getting it
to run everywhere.
You can take your HTML5
app and, a la PhoneGap,
there are adapter technologies
for making the whole thing
run inside Android
and iOS platforms
that don't support WebGL yet.
Android, less of an issue now,
because most of the Android
devices actually do it.
And one I'm talking
about here is CocoonJS.
The Cocoon folks in
the room somewhere?
I know they're kicking around.
It's a company called Ludei.
They are in San
Francisco, and they
make a technology that
basically implements the WebGL
API and a couple of other APIs
that aren't built into iOS
or easy to use in iOS.
And they give you some tools
for making that all easy.
And basically, with very
little change to your code,
you can adapt that and bring
it into iOS and make an app.
They'll even make
the app for you.
Hey, you're not an iOS coder?
They'll build it.
They got a cloud service
doing it for you,
all you have to do is sign
it with your developer ID
and submit it to the store.
So that's really
great, and I encourage
you to go look at that.
Getting really close, here.
So, my opinion.
And this is why I'm so
happy we're here tonight.
And Peter, thank you, again.
And Don Olmstead, thank you
for suggesting I come here
and talk tonight.
I think we're getting
to a tipping point.
A year ago Microsoft,
WebGL, I don't know.
Security?
Whatever, blah, blah, blah.
Well they changed their
tune, and they're really
supporting WebGL pretty well.
I went into Best Buy, I went up
to a laptop, I hit a URL I knew
was a WebGL URL with
Internet Explorer--
I didn't go sneakily download
Chrome like I usually
do on every machine
I go to at Best Buy--
I just went and hit
it, and it worked.
I hit that "100,000 Stars," I
hit that Car, all those things
I showed you, they
all just worked.
So that's great.
I mentioned the Kindle Fire HDX.
I don't know if we're going
to get this on camera,
but, let's see here, come on.
Yeah, here we go.
So here's a little interactive
piece I built for my book.
I don't know if you
can see it from here.
Car spinning around.
I took this untouched-- It
just worked-- out of the box.
This thing I built
in HTML5 in WebGL.
And then I added touch events
so I can zoom and touch
on different pieces
of the model.
That took me half a day
to add the touch support.
Good to go.
Running at 60 frames a
second, this thing streams.
Amazing.
Seven inch, great deal.
Go get one.
And then we have another
speaker tonight, Don Olmstead,
who I just mentioned.
He works at Sony, and
you know what he did?
He built the entire
PS4 interface in WebGL.
So there we go.
Four plus million seats in
one whack, WebGL powered.
God bless you.
The people who track browser
stats-- this is a good one.
You know that NORAD
website that tracks
Santa's progress around
the globe every year?
So, they've had a WebGL thing
for the last couple of years,
and we saw 146%
increase in people
who got into the 3D experience.
Which meant their browser
actually supported WebGL,
mostly was the issue.
I mentioned this, Opera is now
powering a Bang and Olufsen TV
with their devices, SDK.
So we have smart TVs
with full HTML5 in them.
And tonight's event, I think we
broke all the records, right?
So WebGL definitely
about to tip the scales,
and I'm personally
delighted, and I
think this is really exciting.
People's enthusiasm for this
has been just incredible,
this event tonight.
So I encourage you
to stay in touch.
All my particulars are here.
Like I said, the slide show is
going to be up on SlideShare
for you.
So all the URLs will be there.
And I was just
talking to Vanessa,
and I think what I'm going
to do is ask O'Reilly
to get me a promo
code so anybody
from this meet-up
tonight can get
a free version of the
new book as an eBook.
The print one you've
got to pay for.
And I'll sign it, I promise.
So we'll make sure that
we get you the new book.
But if you go on Amazon,
search for my name,
you'll see these
two titles up there.
And with that, thank
you again, Peter.
And go forth.
[APPLAUSE]